[Music]  Tiffany Haddish pulled out all the stops  at the 2018 MTV movie and TV Awards the  comedian hosted the annual show fusing  her signature sense of humor into pretty  much everything not only did Tiffany  wrap car DB she also transformed into  her after a little flirting with Michael  B Jordan there was also some steamy  tension with Adam driver in this Star  Wars parody why is the force connecting  us I don't know but I ain't mad epic  fashion was front and center  Tiffany channel JLo Megan Markel and of  course rocked her favorite Alexander  McQueen gown again and impressive the  girls trip star not only hosted the show  she also went home a winner  [Applause]  [Music]